you know I spent about 20 minutes like
here on the house for like I must have a
little black box and I don't so no real
opening gag
[Applause]
[Music]
the power of three this is another
episode that I think is over hated and
over maligned there's actually a fair
amount that I like about this episode
especially going back and re watching it
and knowing what's coming and realizing
how much of the impact of Angels Take
Manhattan is built on foundation laid in
this episode I think there's a lot to
like here there are issues I'll get to
them so I love the core concept of this
for multiple reasons there there's a few
different things going on here and most
of them I really like I like this
technique for the invasion where these
boxes just show up and do nothing for
months so that people don't take them
seriously anymore they ignore them they
use them as paperweights like oh look
it's a cube like what brilliant idea
that's that's weird and bizarre and
that's an alien concept that's what I
love about that is that it's a way of
infiltrating and attacking a planet that
humans wouldn't think of it's an alien
thought process so I love that right off
the bat I like the idea of the doctor
having just stick around on the planet
and keep an eye on these things and he's
bored I love that I think that works
especially well with the doctor it's
high-energy as Matt Smith's doctor
that's terrific
so I am down for all of that I like how
it is examining the way in which a mere
Ori are maturing and how they're kind of
ready for normal life to start and
that's kind of what I mean by Factory
and laying groundwork
four angels in Manhattan so we'll we'll
get to that episode when we get to it
but I think as sad as what happens there
is I think it helps soften the
deliberately I think it helps soften the
blow by giving you this episode as
reassurance of Amy and Rory together
we'll be okay even without the doctor it
shows how they aren't dependent on him
how they enjoy him they like being with
him Amy especially but they're ready for
just life and it's this episode deals
with the idea of a home life and what's
left back on earth for the companions in
a way that is far more interesting to me
than the home dramatics that say Davies
kept dealing with because the way Davies
would tackle this sort of thing was
always you know well Rose has her mother
who's back on earth and martha has her
parents who are back on earth and Donna
has her mother lots of parents but like
that that to me is not an interesting
way to address the earth life of a
companion but addressing the fact that
they are physically older than their
friends because they basically have
months worth of additional living that
they've done in other points in time and
how that is affecting their
relationships and their perceptions and
their sense of self and the world around
them and and you know Brian you know
asked asked him you know how long were
you just gone because they came back in
close you know I'd like Rory's dad being
on to the doctor and and what he's doing
and I love the honesty of the doctors
answer to Brian about
what has happened to other companions in
the past I think that's really sweet I I
think there is a lot that works really
well here I like Kate Stewart I love her
introduction on this I like that the
doctor clocks are pretty quickly I'll I
love that the Brigadier has a legacy in
unit I love her attitude her approach
her her eagerness to work with a doctor
but at the same time the no-nonsense
things she's got going on some of her
later appearances aren't nearly as good
but she's got a great introduction in
this however we have to kind of get to
the big elephant in the room when it
comes to the problem with this thing and
that's the tail end and the explanation
and resolution or actually even before
we get to that can we just address like
the the orderlies or nurses or whatever
they were would like that black things
in their mouths they look like they were
look like somebody hit pause mid
transformation of the the empty child
from series one I don't know what the
point of them was like I really don't I
I don't they're just there to be a
threat of some I don't know don't get it
at all this I like I don't get it like
what are those that no I get what they
are but i merit of lee i don't know why
they're there and then there's this
whole idea of this entire thing being
orchestrated by this legendary thing
that the doctor has heard stories about
from his childhood on Gallifrey and
there's a lot of problems with this so
first off it's pulling the basically
just trying to stop the spread of
humanity which is not new like that's
that's really well-trodden ground
for science fiction and I mean he even
relatively recently you know that's
that's what the that's what cue and the
continuum kept sort of circling back to
whether or not they wanted to do that in
you know starting with Star Trek The
Next Generation and then there's this
whole idea of like this thing is a
legendary being that you know it's a
Gallifreyan legend and the doctor just
beats it I'm sorry what now
it actually in that way bears more than
a passing resemblance to can you hear me
from series 12 and I love can you hear
me and while I understand the issue I
just talked about from power of three
some people have that same issue with
can you hear me it I don't have an issue
with it there although I do see why some
people do but the reason why I give it a
pass and can you hear me is because can
you hear me it has a lot going on the
matically and metaphorically and
allegorically that the resolution for me
fits with the theming of everything else
going on here while there is more going
on under the surface than just there are
boxes and it's some kind of invasion
because you know we're establishing a
whole lot about Amy and Rory's
relationship their dependency on the
doctor or the fading of their dependency
how much the doctor means them the
nature of that bond and everything so
there's stuff going on on the surface
but it's it's character stuff it's not
the Mattocks stuff so there isn't a
thematic justification for why that
conclusion goes down the way it is
there's a thematic reason why can you
hear me happens the way it does that's
not really the case here this is just a
really rushed conclusion because they
needed a way to wrap this thing up you
really do get the feeling that they came
in with a set up for the boxes and it
takes a while and it's like the slow
invasion or whatever it is that it gets
referenced as at the beginning but they
didn't know how they were going to wrap
it up and so they spent why
37 minutes just dwelling with this leg
ooh what's going on and then eight
minutes ramping it up real quick and
there we go
move on it was like they came up with us
they they spent a lot of time figure out
a really cool setup and then like 10
minutes figuring out how they were gonna
wrap it up and having it be this big
legendary thing that is this easily
defeated like there's no reason for it
to be that you know scale it down you
introducing a threat that big and grand
and legendary even as a doctor and then
having it so thoroughly whooped so
quickly there's no reason for that to be
the case here so that is that is an
issue and I guess some people find the
stuff even before the conclusion a
little bit boring I don't especially
idle rewatch I like it even more but
that does make that ending all the more
frustrating because honestly the stuff
prior to them going on the ship where
the where this stuff's all being
puppeted is really good like the stuff
with Kate's good Amy Rory's good Brian's
good the doctors good the boxes are neat
as a concept like it's also good and
then the ending doesn't ruin it but the
ending does flatten it like it's
everything else is up here in the
endings down here and it's not like
enough of a nosedive to do I drag
everything down and like ruin it but it
does mean that you know the last eight
minutes of this episode are the least
interesting and engaging and that's
never a good thing
so power three mixed bag this time
around what do you think about it
whatever your thoughts are dropped
something on down the comments let's
talk about a bunch of stuff to do like
subscribe hit me up on patreon I'd super
appreciate it I'm up I'm up over 250
supporters on there which is amazing
let's keep it going
uh and of course all the usual things
then there's links and things for you to
click and merch to buy and it's at
etcetera but you also don't have to
because end of the day you're the
council I'm just running the meetings
and until next time this council is
adjourned
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]